is Dr Martin Luther King Jr day when the
U.S honors one of the most prominent
leaders in the Civil Rights Movement
today marks Dr King's birthday and Las
Vegas is celebrating his life with the
annual parade downtown Candace Charles
live this morning at fourth in gas where
the parade gets underway Candace good
morning to you
good morning YouTube good morning folks
now Wendell P Williams who runs the
parade told me there'll be more than a
hundred entries in the parade and the
parade starts here at 4th and gas at 10
A.M is expected to last about two and a
half hours to four hours I have one of
those injuries here with me today the
young black engineers and they got some
of their work that you'll be seeing in
the parade I have Misha here with me as
well tell me a little bit about this
group here all right so we're
transitioning boys into men who are also
partnered with the National Society of
black Engineers Junior I am the
President of The National Society of
black Engineers here in Las Vegas and we
have our National Society of black
Engineers or nesby Junior program and we
teach them stem Steam and we help them
we teach them how to do robotics code
and things like that and also etiquette
and and school etiquette home etiquette
business etiquette dating etiquette
things like that so they can be better
people for us our families in our
community what an amazing part Luther
King's dream right that's amazing work
living the dream absolutely and we will
get to see some of those robotics today
of young Cyrus here with me to tell me a
little bit about the robots we'll see in
the parade tell me a little bit about it
um pretty much
this looks pretty cool it looks like
it's a little Windmill and it looks like
all of these pieces are are battery
operated or you can turn these on so
people will see them walking around
doing the parade right yes how excited
are you to be in the parade today very
glad to be in the parade again oh that's
amazing so this is another year for you
in the parade yes absolutely absolutely
what is it like out here what's the
energy like when people see you guys
come on down the parade route it's just
very exciting to see a lot of people
cheer for you on on the street just
walking down the Martin Luther King
Parade yeah that's amazing what you guys
enjoy thank you for sharing your bright
Minds with us today you guys can come on
down here and see these youngsters as
well as many more starting at 10 o'clock
here at Fourth and gas of course about
details about the parade or route and
more on the website newsnow.com isn't
this so cool you guys look at that one
of them's going right now
it's amazing